Quand on est en avant,
.c. NV
- C'est nous deux qu'on
dirigeait le Rabaska.
Quand on est en avant,
on a tout le bateau à diriger.
- Cette sortie sur la Rivières-
des-Prairies est très spéciale.
Toutefois, ces élèves de
6e année ont l'habitude
d'être dehors. Ils profitent
régulièrement de l'enseignement
en plein air, tant pour
l'éducation physique que
pour les matières de base.
- Dans la nature, on découvre
plus le monde. On peut
travailler avec le soleil,
c'est comme plus confortable
(autre c'est mieux) C'est plus
- Ça nous apprend de la vie tout
- le risque elle dispose d'une
flotte de vélos. Également d'une
flotte de raquettes pour
l'hiver. Surtout les enseignants
croient aux bienfaits de
l'apprentissage extérieur.
Quelques études internationales
ont dévoilé les effets positifs.
Notamment sur l'attention et la
réduction du stress.
- L'apprentissage plein air
augmente la santé des enfants.
C'est une étude québécoise.
- Les chercheurs ont comparé
deux groupes de sixièmes années.
L'une des deux offres
l'enseignement en plein air sur
une base régulière.
- Pendant une semaine les
éléments portés un
accéléromètre.
travailler dehors que dans
- Données à l'appui, l'étude
conclut que les élèves du
programme plein air bougent plus
que les autres aux récréations,
et se rapprochent ainsi des
recommandations quotidiennes.
- Les enfants qui participent
aux activités d'apprentissage
plein air "toppent"
les 60 minutes. Donc, ça permet
aux garçons d'arriver
aux 60 minutes recommandées.
Et ce qui est très intéressant,
c'est que cet effet-là est
davantage prononcé chez
les filles, et c'est important
parce que c'est les filles
qui s'éloignent le plus
des 60 minutes recommandées
d'activités physiques.
- Ce n'est peut-être pas encore
l'antidote à l'abus du temps
d'écran, mais l'étude révèle
que les élèves qui profitent
de l'école dehors sont plus
raisonnables dans leurs temps
de loisirs.
YANICK LACOSTE, cherch., science
de l'activité physique, UQAM
- Chez les enfants qui faisaient
de l'apprentissages plein air,
eh bien, on a eu une réduction
ou plutôt une stabilisation de
la progression du temps d'écran.
- Je sors plus souvent qu'à
l'habitude, pour sortir avec
mes amis, jouer dehors.
- Ce sont des résultats qui
donnent envie aux chercheurs de
mesurer les effets à plus grande
échelle, mais aussi d'encourager
les enseignants, de plus en plus
nombreux, à sortir de
leur classe.
- Il faudrait pouvoir les
écouter, qu'ils deviennent
des diffuseurs de toute cette
approche-là qui est somme toute
un peu nouvelle dans notre
province.
- Nous, on a de la chance.
On a de la chance!
♪ ♪ ♪
- Les élèves, eux, ne sont plus
à convaincre.
Ici Anne-Louise Despaties,
Radio-Canada, Montréal.